foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if we go to film they beat us and attack
us people are not allowed to go graze
their sheep they're not allowed to go to
school and they're not allowed to move
any place and even if the army not
preventing them they'll be afraid
because there are tanks moving around
bulldozers and soldiers shooting and
they're bombing
this is violating the international law
and human rights law because
the communities were existing since
hundreds of years
in massachusetts we have our traditions
our whole community our homes our land
our simple life that our grand
grandparents used to live
in
foreign
[Music]
here it's every day when we face
soldiers and settlers attacks or
physically attacked by settlers
harassments also against us against our
shepherds against school students
also soldiers come or doing the training
in the communities or coming to demolish
our homes this i've been
witnessing and documenting uh
almost all all my life
we don't have much power but we are
using every single
thing that we can to to stop this we are
here to fight and to resist for our
rights
[Music]
exercising that they're doing
it
brought a lot of fear because they're
bombing they're shooting they go with
tanks nearby the houses we believe that
that
if there's a hope to stop this should
come from the international community
and we want
our voices our stories our videos our
articles
to be to reach
those people so we we still have the
hope because we we believe that we hold
the right and
the right should win in the end